we're already familiar with the
chi-squared statistic if you're not I
encourage you to review the videos on
that and we've already done some
hypothesis testing with the chi-squared
statistic and we've even done some
hypothesis testing based on two-way
tables and now we're going to extend
that by thinking about a chi-squared
test for association between two
variables so let's say that we suspect
that someone's foot length is related to
their hand length that these things are
not independent what we can do is set up
a hypothesis test and remember the ha
the null hypothesis is an in a
hypothesis test is to always assume no
news so what we could say is here is
that there is no association no
association between between foot and
hand length another way to think about
it is that they are independent and
often times what we're doing is called a
chi-square test for independence and
then our alternative hypothesis would be
our suspicion there is an association
there is an association so foot and hand
lengths are not independent so what we
can then do is go to a population and we
can randomly sample it and so let's say
we randomly sample 100 folks and for all
of those hundred folks we figure out
whether their right hand is longer their
left hand is longer or both hands are
the same and we also do that for the
feet and we tabulate all of the data and
this is the data that we actually get
now it's worth thinking about this for a
second on how what we just did is
different from a chi-squared test for
homogeneity and a chi-squared test for
homogeneity we sample from two different
populations or we look at two different
groups and we see whether the
distribution of a certain variable
amongst those two different groups is
the same here we are just sampling from
one group but we're thinking about two
different
variables for that one group we're
thinking about feet length and worked in
thinking about hand length and so you
can see here that eleven folks had both
their right hand longer and their right
foot longer three folks had their right
hand longer and but their left foot was
longer and then eight folks had their
right hand longer but both feet were the
same likewise we had nine people where
their left foot and hand was longer but
he had two people where the left hand
was longer but the right foot was longer
and we could go through all of these but
to do our chi-square test we would have
said what would be the expected value of
each of these data points if we assumed
that the null hypothesis was true that
there was no association between foot
and hand length so to help us do that
I'm gonna make a total of our columns
here and also a total of our rows here
let me draw a line here so we know what
where is going on and so what are the
total number of people who had a longer
right hand well it's going to be 11 plus
3 plus 8 which is 22 the total number of
people who had a longer left hand is 2
plus 9 plus 14 which is 25 and then the
total number of people whose hands had
the same length 12 plus 13 plus 28 25
plus 28 that is 53 and then if I were to
total this column 22 plus 25 is 47 plus
53 we get a hundred right over here and
then if we total the number of people
who had a longer right foot 11 plus 2
plus 12 is 13 plus 12 that is 25 longer
left foot 3 plus 9 plus 13 that's also
25 and then we could either add these up
and we would get 50 or we could say hey
25 plus 25 plus what is 100 well that is
going to be equal to 50 now to figure
out these expected values remember we're
going to figure out the expected values
assuming that the null hypothesis is
true assuming that these distributions
are independent that feet length and
hand length are independent variables
well if
they are independent which we are
assuming then our best estimate is that
22 percent have a longer right hand and
our best estimate is that 25 percent
have a longer right foot and so out of a
hundred you would expect zero point two
two times 0.25 times 100 to have a
longer right hand and foot I'm just
multiplying the probabilities which you
would do what if these were independent
variables and so zero point two two
times zero point two five let's see one
fourth of 22 is five and a half so this
is going to be equal to five point five
now what number would you expect to have
a longer right hand but a longer left
foot so that would be zero point two two
times zero point two five times 100 well
we already calculated what that would be
that would be five point five and then
to figure out the expected number that
it would have a longer right hand but
both feet would be the same length we
could multiply 22 out of 100 times 50
out of 100 times 100 which is going to
be half of 22 which is equal to 11 and
we can keep going this value right over
here would be 0.25 times 0.25 times 100
25 times 25 is 625 so that would be six
point two five this value right over
here would be 0.25 times 0.25 times 100
which is again six point two five and
then this value right over here a couple
of ways we can get it we can multiply
0.25 times 50 times 100 which would get
us to 12.5 or we could have said this
Plus this Plus this has to equal 25 so
this would be 12.5 and now this expected
value we can figure out because five
point five plus six point two five Plus
this is going to equal 25 so let's see
five point five plus six point two five
is eleven point seven five eleven point
seven five plus thirteen point two five
is equal to 25 same thing over
here this would be thirteen point two
five because this is eleven point seven
five plus thirteen point two five is
equal to 25 if we add these two together
we get twenty six point five twenty six
point five plus what is equal to fifty
three would be equal to another twenty
six point five now once you figure out
all of your expected values that's a
good time to test your conditions the
first condition is that you took a
random sample so let's assume we had
done that the second condition is that
your expected value for any of the data
points has to be at least equal to five
and we can see that all of our expected
values are at least equal to five the
actual data points we got do not have to
be equal to five so it's okay that we
got a two here because the expected
value here is five or larger and then
the last condition is the independence
condition that either we are sampling
with replacement or that we have to feel
comfortable that our sample size is no
more than 10% of the population so let's
assume that that happened as well so
assuming we met all of those conditions
we are ready to calculate our
chi-squared statistic and so what we're
going to do is for every data point
we're going to find the difference
between the data point 11 minus the
expected minus 5 point 5 squared over
the expected so I did that one now I'll
do this one so plus 3 minus 5.5 squared
over 5 point 5 plus and I'll do this one
8 minus 11 squared over 11 then I'll do
this one 2 minus 6 point 2 5 squared
over 6 point 2 5 and I'll keep doing it
I'm going to do it for all nine of these
data points and I actually calculated
this ahead of time to save some time and
so if you do this for all nine of the
data points you're going to get a
chi-square statistic of eleven point
nine for two
now before we calculate the p-value
we're gonna have to think about what are
our degrees of freedom now we have a
three by three table here so one way to
think about it it's the number of rows
minus one
the number of columns minus 1 this is 2
times 2 which is equal to 4 another way
to think about it is if you know 4 of
these data points and you know the
totals then you could figure out the
other five data points and so now we are
ready to calculate a p-value and you
could do that using a calculator and you
could do that using a chi-square table
but let's say we did it using a
calculator and we get a p-value of 0.01
8 and just to remind ourselves what this
is this is the probability of getting a
chi-square statistic at least this large
or larger and so next we do what we
always do with hypothesis testing we
compare this to our significance level
and we actually should have set our
significance level from the beginning so
let's just assume that when we set up
our hypotheses here we also said that we
want a significance level of 0.05 you
really should do this before you
calculate all of this but then you kept
you compare your p-value to your
significance level and we see that this
p-value is a good bit less than our
significance level and so one way to
think about it is we got all these
expected values assuming that the null
hypothesis was true but the probability
of getting a result this extreme or more
extreme is less than 2% which is lower
than our significance level and so this
will lead us to reject our null
hypothesis and it suggests to us that
there is an association between hand
length and foot lengths